it actually smells exactly like the mall
hey what's up my name is Calista Mae I'm
a professional pastry chef production
supervisor for Magnolia Bakery Los
Angeles and host of West's series Six
Feet Under
desserts to die for where I travel the
country and find unique desserts and the
people behind them today I'm gonna be
reviewing some store-bought cookie
dough's let's go when I'm looking for a
really good cookie I want it to be fudgy
chewy maybe a little salt maybe I'm
getting ahead of myself cuz these are
store-bought the first cookie we're
diving into it's gonna be Pillsbury you
know Pillsbury the cute little dough boy
you want to poke his stomach he's
somehow always in your kitchen and it
doesn't really make sense its little you
don't really see that many chocolate
chips in it and when I want to chocolate
chip cookie I want to see a lot of
chocolate make it look really chunky and
inviting kind of really blond to a
chocolate chip cookie with a little more
darkness and color to it I think to me
makes me think there's gonna be more
flavor it kind of reminds me exactly of
that perfect childhood store-bought
cookie and I think the nostalgia of that
and the nostalgia of Pillsbury that
always warms my heart I'm pleasantly
surprised by this one
it's almost under baked in the center
which I love it's not too sweet I could
definitely see me smashing a good amount
of these without noticing oh I'm just
watching TV I think I would want the
chocolate to be a little more pronounced
and maybe a little darker because it is
pretty sweet cookie number two Nestle
Tollhouse or sorry I think I pronounced
that wrong I believe Phoebe Buffay
pronounces it Nesta Nate widow's it
looks like a really good chocolate chip
cookie it's got more color than the
first one which I like it's got visible
chocolate chips which of course you want
to see in a chocolate chip cookie when
you break it open nice texture chewy
they loaded this up with chocolate which
is exactly what I'm looking for
it looks a little more homemade so let's
taste it flashbacks of childhood one of
my best friends and I she would come
over every Sunday get a tube of this eat
it raw this is really good it kind of
oddly tastes like Halloween chocolate in
a good way really sweet but chocolatey
undertones this is just such a good
go-to chocolate chip cookie cookie
number three
this is gonna be Betty Crocker's
chocolate chip oatmeal cookie we got
some oatmeal in here so I guess that
means it's healthier this probably looks
the most from scratch made this is the
only one that is a cookie mix so I did
have to add butter and egg and a little
bit of water I know so hard the oatmeal
adds a little texture to it inside it's
beautiful the chips really help their
shape they're nice and big and they
actually look like they're pretty evenly
dispersed throughout the cookie I really
like this one I think the oats really
make it stand out so it does have this
really nice subtle toasted flavor to it
the chocolate too isn't super sweet I
feel like out of the ones I've tried so
far this one tastes the most semi-sweet
a little more on the darker side last
but not least we're breaking into mrs.
Fields I think of the mall when I think
of mrs. fields and remember walking
through the mall and you get that whiff
of the fresh-baked cookies that like a
cartoon you know like picks you up off
your feet
the hand of smoke and smell brings me to
every storefront these look the best
come on
these are huge tons of chocolate I think
it has a really beautiful color it's
nice and dark it's got all these little
nooks and crannies cracks oh yeah it
actually smells exactly like the mall no
just weird or good i beneath this that's
a really good cookie it is a little bit
drier than when you get them from the
actual storefronts or mrs. fields
I will say though that the bake time
suggestion on the package was completely
off it said to bake him for 10 to 12
minutes at 325 and just reading that I
was like no and I had to add at least
another eight to ten minutes and I like
the chocolate chips in this one they
really held their shape they're an
actual bigger chip they're still in the
semi-sweet family none of these really
had a dark chocolate chip I think it
would help with balancing the sweetness
moment of truth I get to choose which
one of these store-bought brands is my
favorite and I gotta say the winner is
drumroll Betty Crocker's oatmeal
chocolate chip I actually loved the oats
in it I love the texture it wasn't
overtly sweet it looks and tastes the
most from scratch for store-bought I see
you Betty all in all though these are
all pretty decent cookies and I think if
you're in a pinch you don't want to
spend a lot of time in the kitchen any
of these would be a really good option
but of course I'm gonna say if you have
the time and make your own cookies from
scratch the biggest thing to remember is
that you want to use more brown sugar
than white sugar the molasses and the
brown sugar will give you that chewier
texture thanks for tuning in I'm gonna
take these cookies my favorite and feed
on my mane I'll see you later
you
[Music]
[Applause]